Revisore: Michele Gianella
Che giornata, eh?
Vi piacciono i TED allora? Vi piace TED?
Bene.
Anche a me piace tantissimo.
Per spiegarvi le emozioni
che sto vivendo in questo momento,
dovete capire che nel 2005,
quando ho scoperto i TED su Internet,
sono andato fuori di testa.
Sono pochi quelli che non ho
ancora visto, dal 2005 ad oggi.
Per cui sono tantissime ore,
alcune sprecate,
altre veramente guadagnate,
con tante storie.
Io quindi ho prima imparato
cosa fosse un TEDTalk,
poi sono arrivato in Italia, nel 2007,
e ho imparato l'italiano.
Quindi oggi sono quasi pronto
per fare un TEDTalk in italiano
per riflettere su qualcosa
di molto importante,
che mi sta molto a cuore,
insieme a voi.
Ed è proprio dal mio arrivo in Italia
che vorrei partire.
Immaginatevi questa scena:
io e il mio nuovo coinquilino
apriamo i nostri bagagli
e cominciamo a sistemarci
nella nostra nuova stanza doppia,
qui proprio in centro a Udine.
Io vengo da Israele,
lui viene dalla Palestina.
Nei prossimi tre anni,
abiteremo insieme ad altri ragazzi
provenienti da paesi
in conflitto tra di loro.
Vivremo in questo appartamento
imparando tantissime cose
gli uni degli altri.
E tantissime altre cose su noi stessi.
Lui tira fuori qualche fotografia,
che appoggia sul comodino;
e poi tira fuori
la bandiera nazionale della Palestina.
Si rivolge a me e mi chiede:
"Scusa, dov'è la tua bandiera?"
"Non la vedo sul muro,
e non voglio mettere la mia
se tu non metti la tua."
Io, imbarazzato, rispondo:
"Non ho portato la mia bandiera,
non mi piacciono molto queste cose."
In realtà però mi sembra il caso,
quindi vedo di risolvere.
E così ho fatto.
E questa è proprio la stanza
dove abbiamo vissuto assieme.
Pubblico: Meritate un applauso
PK: (Risate)
(Applausi)
Grazie.
E questo è solo l'inizio,
dunque non posso finirla qui, no?
Vedete, sembra sempre più difficile
vivere su questa Terra.
Questa avveniva dieci anni fa, quasi.
E sembra sempre più difficile.
Sembra essere tutto in crisi:
crisi politica; crisi economica;
crisi valoriali; crisi ambientale.
Crisi tra amanti,
la crisi degli immigranti.
A volte, non serve nemmeno specificare.
Basta dire "la crisi", come se fosse
una spiegazione a tutto.
Bene, in questa confusione
soltanto una cosa mi era chiara:
se vogliamo vivere meglio,
se vogliamo uscirne assieme
da questa confusione,
allora dobbiamo imparare la convivenza.
Dobbiamo imparare a vivere assieme.
Sembra tutto rotto, no?
Ecco, stasera invece voglio parlarvi
della lezione che io
ho imparato sulla convivenza.
Vi va di sentire un po'?
Perché cosa [potrebbe succedere]
se invece di avere paura,
se invece di rompere tutto,
se invece di vivere
questi cambiamenti epocali
con preoccupazione,
capissimo che la preoccupazione
è la stessa da ambo le parti?
Colui che arriva da lontano,
e viene in Italia,
ha paura di essere escluso.
E colui che vive in Italia,
e vede gli arrivi,
ha paura di essere escluso.
Questa è la tragedia.
Ed il nostro futuro e società
saranno sempre più multiculturali,
sempre più multireligiose,
sempre più multietniche.
Se noi non ci prepariamo a questa realtà,
le conseguenze saranno disastrose.
Si romperà veramente tutto.
Però, cosa succederà se invece
saremo abbastanza intelligenti
da preparare noi stessi in primis,
poi i nostri figli, la nostra società
a questo nuovo futuro,
in cui l'umanità continua a dialogare,
continua a creare nuove identità?
Ad evolvere, a sognare assieme
come abbiamo sentito anche prima?
Che futuro possiamo immaginarci?
Perché il progresso non torna indietro.
Allora ci adeguiamo a lui.
Per farvi capire cosa significa,
vivevamo in sette in quell'appartamento;
però abbiamo sempre raccontato
che con noi abitava un altro,
una specie di piccolo mostro.
Un mostriciattolo che noi
abbiamo chiamato, affettuosamente,
"Fraintendimento".
Perché i fraintendimenti, tra noi,
erano pane quotidiano.
Potevano essere fraintendimenti piccoli,
come tutte quelle tazze di tè
che ho preparato di troppo
perché non ho capito che, per i turchi,
questo movimento della testa
significa "No".
(Risate)
Ci sono voluti, direi,
due litri e mezzo di tè
per capire che c'era
qualcosa che non andava,
per cui chiedevo:
"Scusa, Non volevi il tè?
No, ho fatto così."
"Appunto, hai fatto segno di sì, o no?"
Potevano essere questo tipo
di fraintendimenti;
però, potevano anche essere
fraintendimenti più profondi.
Come una volta, di cui
mi ricordo chiaramente.
Dopo un incontro che avevamo
tenuto in una scuola,
e che a mio avviso era andato
particolarmente bene,
Il mio amico palestinese
sembrava pensieroso.
Un po' cupo.
E gli chiedevo il motivo,
cercavo di indagare
su cosa fosse successo.
Solo per scoprire che non era pensieroso.
Era arrabbiatissimo,
ed era arrabbiato con me.
"Cosa ho fatto?" gli chiedevo;
e lui: "Ma non ti rendi conto?"
Con un altro accento,
ma questo è un altro discorso.
"Non ti rendi conto?"
Manco fosse stata la mia ragazza.
"E dunque?"
È caduto l'orologio,
per segnare il problema del tempo.
E lui --
Io continuo a chiedere
cos'è successo in quell'incontro,
visto che è andato così bene.
Invece, così non era per lui.
Scopro che ad un certo punto dell'incontro
io ho incrociato le gambe,
volgendo a lui la mia scarpa.
Quel giorno scoprivo che nel mondo arabo
questo è considerato un insulto diretto.
E che ai politici più disprezzati
non si lanciano le uova,
né i pomodori, ma le scarpe.
Per cui quel giorno ho pensato
che ho ancora tanta strada da fare.
Però col tempo --
e di tempo parliamo oggi --
col tempo abbiamo parlato --
abbiamo imparato, scusate -- a conoscerci.
Abbiamo imparato molto
sulle nostre identità.
E le identità sono cose importanti.
Tante volte, quando parliamo d'identità,
ci sembra di parlare di una cosa chiara.
Una cosa unica, una cosa rigida.
Un po' come la carta d'identità, no?
Ma non è così.
Le identità aiutano a definire le persone.
Per cui: questo è un italiano;
questo è un extracommunitario;
questo è un musulmano;
quell'altro un ebreo, e via dicendo.
Di conseguenza,
poi appiccichiamo a questa persona
anche altre etichette.
Per cui:
gli italiani? Mafiosi!
Gli ebrei? Tutti ricchi!
(Dialetto ) i friuliani?
Sempre a lavorare!
Non voi che siete qua,
però: gli altri fuori!
Bene.
Questo è pericoloso,
perché se considero di te
soltanto una dimensione,
è facile che abbiamo un conflitto.
Se io credo in Dio e tu no,
non andremo mai d'accordo su nulla.
Vero?
No, che non è vero.
Sappiamo che non è così, perché --
Lei è più padre o più figlio?
Lei è più religioso o più italiano?
Più donna o più credente?
Non sono cose che si escludono!
Le nostre identità non sono mai piatte,
sono pluridimensionali.
A volte sono conflittuali
dentro noi stessi.
Ma sono sempre, sempre coloratissime.
E quindi, così --
Se imparo a conoscere,
se dedico del tempo a conoscere
il mio amico palestinese,
scopro di lui che è credente, musulmano,
ma un po' a modo suo.
Scopro che è patriottico,
ma estremamente critico
sul proprio Governo.
Scopro che vive di zuccheri,
ne mangia una quantità
veramente imbarazzante.
Ma che il piccante lo tollero meglio io.
Per cui, più dimensioni di lui
imparo a conoscere,
più cose trovo che abbiamo in comune,
queste dimensioni che abbiamo
in comune s'intrecciano.
E tessono assieme
una specie di rete di sicurezza
per il nostro rapporto.
Vi spiego perché.
Se litighiamo la prossima volta
su uno degli aspetti --
sulla fede, piuttosto che della politica,
piuttosto che del piccante
o dello zucchero --
litighiamo su quella dimensione lì.
Ma io e lui conosciamo
talmente tante altre cose l'uno dell'altro
che anche se spezziamo
uno di questi fili della rete
il tessuto resta intero,
e noi riusciamo a stare assieme lo stesso.
Questa è la stessa cosa
che capita nelle famiglie e tra gli amici.
Non è che non si litighi: si litiga,
ma ci sono tante altre cose che ci legano.
Bisogna avere del tempo
per conoscersi, per questo.
Adesso mi direte, però,
come per l'applauso di prima.
"Ah, ma quello vostro
era un progetto particolare.
Eravate predisposti, scelti magari,
tra tante persone in Palestina e Israele,
quelli bravi, vero? I brâv.
Per cui siete persone speciali, voi.
Un po' come Gandhi."
Persone non-violente,
come se fosse un gene.
Bene, allora vi chiedo stasera:
"Che cos'è la non-violenza?"
Ovvero: "Come si fa la non-violenza?"
Non è una domanda filosofica, attenzione:
se voglio essere una persona pacifica,
una persona non-violenta,
devo capire come comportarmi.
Ma le parole non mi aiutano,
mi dicono soltanto cosa non fare:
non-violenza.
Non mi propongono un impegno positivo.
Per cui, per tanti anni
mi sono interrogato sulla violenza stessa.
Ho cercato una definizione
chiara e tonda per la violenza.
Perché se riesco a definire la violenza,
magari trovo una buona definizione
del suo opposto, il suo contrario.
Per cui riesco ad impegnarmi
in quella direzione.
Non era facile,
ci sono voluti un po' di anni,
ma oggi --
Vi dimostro la mia definizione,
che traggo dall'ebraico.
Chiaro, no?
Sopra c'è la parola "violenza"
in ebraico: "alimut".
Sotto c'è un'altra parola ebraica,
che contiene la stessa radice etimologica.
E la seconda parola è "ilem":
"muto", colui che non può parlare.
Che legame ci sarebbe?
Io ne deduco che la violenza
è l'atto di rendere muto qualcuno.
Attenzione:
questo è vero a livello verbale,
a livello fisico, a livello ideologico,
tutto quello che volete.
E non solo: significa, anche,
che non serve usare la forza
per essere violento.
Basta non dare ascolto alla persona.
Basta ignorare quello che dice.
Del resto, quanto ci infastidisce
quando una persona
fa finta di parlare con noi,
mentre guarda il proprio cellulare.
Non è che gli urlo subito:
"Oh, mi ascolti?"
Ecco.
Se la violenza è l'atto
di rendere muto qualcuno,
il suo opposto è l'ascolto.
E non soltanto l'ascolto
in cui preparo la mia risposta
mentre ti ascolto,
perché so già cosa vuoi dirmi,
e so già quale sarà la mia risposta.
Questo non è ascolto.
Ho sentito una definizione
che diceva che è un "bilologo":
così sono due monologhi assieme,
ma non stiamo parlando veramente.
L'ascolto è questo.
L'ascolto è presumere
che io non abbia capito.
Non ho capito perché ho fatto
delle tazze di tè di troppo,
e ho dovuto impararlo.
Non ho capito perche ho offeso --
Non ho capito di aver offeso,
e come l'ho offeso,
il mio amico palestinese
durante l'incontro.
E così non capiamo un sacco di cose
di chi è diverso da noi.
E quindi è soltanto
quando dedichiamo del tempo,
consapevolmente,
ad ascoltare le persone,
specie se sono diverse da noi,
soltanto quando ci rendiamo conto
che non abbiamo capito ancora,
che riusciamo a capire meglio,
che riusciamo a conoscerci.
E questa è la mia definizione
di nonviolenza.
Per cui:
in questi tempi --
e di tempi parliamo stasera --
in questi tempi così tumultuosi,
e così difficili,
vengono fuori tutte le nostre fragilità,
e noi cerchiamo la stabilità.
Vengono fuori tutte queste crisi,
e noi cerchiamo le opportunità.
Ci sono delle persone,
delle forze, anche forze politiche,
che cercano di dividerci;
e noi cerchiamo nuove reti,
nuove unioni, nuove fratellanze.
È bene se ci ricordiamo in questi tempi
che questa terra è la casa
di tutti quanti noi.
E dobbiamo imparare a conviverci.
Dobbiamo imparare la convivenza.
Se stasera mi chiedete
se questa convivenza sia possibile,
allora posso raccontarvi
la mia esperienza,
e dire che possiamo, assolutamente,
rendere questa terra una casa accogliente
per tutti quanti noi,
se dedichiamo del tempo
ad ascoltare una persona alla volta.
Grazie del vostro ascolto.
(Applausi)